un prêt mesdames et messieurs c'est pas
cher monsieur vous plaît a baissé à la
maison
et
la seule chose que j'ai à vendre c'est
tout ce travail sur mon corps tu peux
être aussi bien des photos qui peut être
une intervention une performance une
action est utile une ouvre d'or à
l'heure actuelle si vous voulez l'art a
changé quand même beaucoup
j'ai plus du tout comme au 19ème siècle
ces puces toute une réflexion et sur
l'histoire de l'art qui tout à coup
produit quelque chose en nous ou une
réflexion sur l'art dans la société et
c'est donc il faut voir si vous voulez
ma démarche non pas comme uniquement un
gadget mais toute une réflexion sur
justement la position de l'art et de
l'artiste et du corps de la femme
à l'heure actuelle et dans la société et
pour moi le gros de la femme est un
matériau nouveau
moi je suis un provincial j'imagine très
bien
excusez moi les gens de toute la france
qui consistera en une télé en sortant
soit leur boulot de l'usiné terrain et
qui ont une certaine idée de l'art et
kelly des raisons de l'arrêt ce qu'ils
ont lu une idée de l'art de ce qui est
ici et sa solide atteindre n'importe
comment enfin qu'est ce que ça veut dire
mais elle est temps de dire que vous
faites de l'art populaire je sais pas
qui disait je vous n'allez pas dire que
tout ce qui est ici est à la portée de
monsieur dumont qui rendent de lusine ça
va le faire marrer on ma montre c'est
déjà bien
après une journée de travail pour moi
qui suis encore un peu traditionalistes
là se traduit par une
c'est une expression avec la pub avec de
la matière c'est une sculpture ça une
existence dans l'espace
et